Donald Trump's plan to pull American
troops out of Syria is drawing fire from
both sides of the aisle in Washington
senior politicians are calling on the
u.s. President to reverse his decision
they're concerned that the pullout will
allow turkey to launch its long-planned
offensive against Kurdish fighters in
the region fighters that have been key
allies of the u.s. in its battle against
the so-called Islamic state leaving in a
hurry American troops started pulling
out of Syria within hours of the
official announcement they leave behind
these empty bases near the Turkish
border bases that had been a guarantee
of safety for Kurdish forces US
President Donald Trump abruptly canceled
that guarantee saying in a tweet it is
time for us to get out of these
ridiculous endless wars many of them
tribal and bring our soldiers home US
troops were in Syria to support Kurdish
forces in the fight against the
so-called Islamic state but Turkey has
long resented the presence of armed
Kurdish forces near its border it
considers them terrorists Kurdish groups
in the region have protested the move
they feel abandoned by the u.s. who
teamed up with Kurdish fighters in the
battle against the is they fear a
Turkish invasion is imminent then - here
I have this green light that Trump gave
to air Dewan will actually complicate
the crisis in the region it will provide
Islamic state with an opportunity to
regenerate and control areas such as
Raqqa and Deir Ezzor again holiday
resort menjadi turkish President Recep
Tayyip Edda won gave the Kurds a stark
warning episode idioms there is a phrase
that we always say we can come any night
without warning and our determination
remains because it is absolutely out of
the question for us to further tolerate
the threats from these terrorist groups
Trump's decision has earned him
widespread criticism even within his
Republican Party so the current
stepped-up when nobody else would
to fight Isis if we abandoned them good
luck getting anybody to help America in
the future will radical Islam al Qaeda
and Isis hours later Trump appeared to
try to placate critics by issuing a
stern warning to Ankara right now we're
at a position where if turkey does
anything out of what they should be
doing we will hit them so hard on the
economy mixed messages at the top and
meanwhile on the ground in Syria the
Kurds are waiting for the next blow to
fall in a region that seen its share of
misery and violence already I'm joined
now by mark Pelini he's a veteran
diplomat in now a visiting scholar at
the Carnegie Europe think-tank he's also
served as EU ambassador to both Syria
and Turkey mr. Peroni thank you very
much for joining us today on DW news why
does the Turkish president want to move
his troops into northern Syria and what
does he intend to do there well
essentially what he intends to do is
ethnic engineering that is removing as
many curse as he can from strip along
the border
he says 30 kilometers and then I have
higher ups and judgments in in power in
these villages and cities this is not
you this is something Turkey has been
saying for a long time it's also the
longtime worry about Kurdistan emerging
on the border in Iraq in Syria and in
Turkey of course but what we're seeing
today since couple of days is basically
two very strong leaders a Don and [ __ ]
with strong narratives and we have to
remember that both of them are in great
trouble politically at home so
essentially they're trying to divert
attention we've heard a lot of words
we've seen a lot of images of armored
vehicles and tanks and so on but we
haven't seen any operation yet so
situation is still in flux but the
dangers are very very high as you just
illustrated in in your reporting first
with Isis
of course the rebirth of Isis is is
possibility second of course more
suffering and and then I believe another
dent in NATO struts in Turkey as you
know Turkey has been an ally in NATO for
many decades but recently the the move
towards a rapprochement with Russia and
so as dented distressed and this
operation here will do more damage
although there is no NATO operation in
northern Syria but it is what's very
carefully here in Brussels now the
European Union clearly has interests at
stake in the region as well what if
anything is the EU doing to help
stabilize that region well as you know
two EU Member States as of today France
and the UK have special forces in the
region cooperating with the US forces
but of course by virtue or the ship the
sheer numbers they are dependent on on
us decisions so that's the first
difficulty then the real issue for
European countries such as France
Belgium Germany UK is that you have
hundreds if not a couple of thousand in
total European jihadists and Families
they're not along the border with Turkey
but further south in particular of the
halal refugee camp and these jihadist
nobody wants to see them return to
Europe and they're under the custody of
YPG the Syrian Kurdish forces so any
destabilization of this situation would
create great dangers for Europe and a
greater worry for political leaders than
refugee mr. peel I need thank you so
much for your insights that was mark
Palani a veteran EU diplomat and now a
visiting scholar at Carnegie Europe